The phone in your hand could be the difference...
...between life and death for our deep seas.
If allowed to go ahead, a new type of mining, called deep seabed mining,...
...will destroy delicate ecosystems on the seabed that have taken millennia to form.
The minerals used in our everyday devices...
like electric cars, laptops and phones…
...might soon be mined from the ocean floor.
But we don't need to mine the deep seabed to gather these minerals.
They already exist in our hands.
We can gather these minerals by recycling our old devices.
It's called urban mining,...
...and only involves digging around in your drawers at home.
Even so, we can do more by consuming less, ...
...so think wisely before you buy a new gadget.
Reduce, reuse and recycle and say no to deep seabed mining.
Or we're in deep trouble.